hello
it is an honor for me to be speaking to
you as part of this very important
symposium
race in america history and
controversies
my focus will be on a key lever that has
been part of a critical foundation for
empowering the black community
to move from persecution to prosperity
that lever is education and the power of
school choice
throughout the struggle for equality of
access and opportunity
the ability for a black parent to choose
a
high quality school for their child
has been the great equalizer for the
black community
but before i share a little bit about
the arduous journey
of the african-american experience of
education in the united states
i'd like to tell you a little bit about
my personal story
in the late 1960s my parents brother and
i
emigrated from jamaica west indies
ultimately moving to
laurelton queens in new york at the time
a predominantly white
middle-class community laurelton was
transitioning from a jewish enclave to
what is now a neighborhood mostly
inhabited by african-american and
caribbean residents
by 1977 i was attending is
231 a junior high school that had been
historically
mostly white but like the surrounding
area
was rapidly becoming racially integrated
racial tensions were growing with
increasingly bitter and daily disputes
driving the school leadership to seek
out solutions
the local school board citing
overcrowding as their rationale
voted to open an annex a separate
academic building two miles away in
rosedale
a small irish and italian american
community
nestled on the border of nassau county
long island
that decision led almost every white
family in my junior high school to
transfer their children
to the annex in september of 1977
leaving is 231 a segregated
virtually all black school my jamaican
immigrant parents
determined that their two sons would get
a real shot at the american dream
were ready to transfer me as well
wherever go the white kids
so goes the quality of the edge of
education was their theory
i was 12 years old and my parents knew
best
but something was not right here i
didn't want to leave my school and i did
not like the reasons my parents were
giving me for doing so
it is a strange and mildly terrifying
thing to consider standing up
to the people you love and up until that
point in my life i had never questioned
my parents about
anything that mattered why would i
question the two people who had
repeatedly demonstrated
that they had only my best interests at
heart
but something inside me said no i found
a voice that i never knew
existed on the sunday evening before
they had to file the transfer documents
i stood in our living room pleading with
my dad and sconced in his brown recliner
and locking eyes with my mom witnessing
her youngest son muster courage
that she had not ever seen i begged my
parents to reconsider
to let me stay in is-231 i remember
thinking to myself and then bravely
saying out loud why should the other
school be better
why should the education suddenly be
worse in my school
just because most of the kids who are
going to be left
are black i like my teachers
and i didn't see why my education would
have to suffer
just because i wasn't going to go to the
school with all the white kids
i told my parents if they let me stay in
is-231
i would work even harder they would not
regret their decision
i promised they could believe in me
because i believed in myself
and regardless of what they were they
were to decide
something had awakened in me to give me
the confidence to respectfully challenge
my parents
i was now an active player in my own
education
and to a larger degree my own destiny
i made a choice i was becoming an
agent of my own uplift
and then something extraordinary
happened my parents relented
they let me stay at is-231
and with the support of my parents and
teachers
i received a public education that made
me believe anything was possible
i ultimately entered brooklyn technical
high school went on to graduate
with a bachelor of science in computer
science engineering at cornell
university
and later earned my mba from harvard
business school
my parents and that choice of education
made all the difference
and now come full circle for the last
decade
i was the ceo of a non-profit network of
public charter schools
in the heart of the south bronx in new
york city hoping to inspire
thousands of low-income primarily black
and hispanic students
to understand the pathways through which
they could become agents of their own
uplift
in a sense the parents of the black and
brown children
i now educated have the same aspirations
that my parents had for me
for many black children and for children
of all races
that education is the ticket to reach
the american dream
but it has not always been so due to the
legacy of slavery
in the mid-1800s black people had very
little access to high quality education
in slave states anti-literacy laws
banned black people from accessing
education
on the premise that a tipping point
of literate slaves might lead to
insurrection and rebellion
for example south carolina had a law
that would
jail a person for six months and impose
crippling fines if you even attempted
to teach a slave to read and write
things did not get much better during
the jim crow era
which legally segregated schools
during that time like much of everyday
life
public schools were segregated by race
they were separate and profoundly
unequal
there were huge disparities in funding
between black and white schools
facilities access to equipment and
most importantly the quality of the
education itself
in 1896 the supreme court
in the case of plessy versus ferguson
ruled
that separate but equal was fair
and was not a violation of the 14th
amendment
requiring equal protection to all
this ruling meant that the federal
government would not
challenge segregation even despite the
deeply
inferior conditions that black students
were subject to
especially in education separate but
equal
and jim crow remained unchallenged
until brown versus board of education in
1954
and the civil rights act of 1964.
it is against this backdrop when racial
segregation was at its worst
that an unlikely partnership transformed
the education
for two generations of black students in
the rural south
educator activist public intellectual
and founder of the tuskegee institute
booker t washington
had himself experienced firsthand
the destitution and profound racial
disparities in the rural south
despite these obstacles washington's
perseverance
and disciplined upbringing eventually
led to an education at what is now known
as hampton university and as an adult
washington dreamed of a school building
project for black communities throughout
the south
that could help begin to lift black
people out of poverty
washington presented his ambitious idea
to build a network of schools
to julius rosenwald who at the time
was a ceo of the nation's largest
retailer
sears rosenwald was a supporter of the
tuskegee institute
so had a deep respectful relationship
with washington
washington collaborated with julius
rosenwald and together they crafted a
plan
to make washington's dream a reality
in a region of the united states in
which jim crow
racial segregation was law lynching was
a common and brutal reality
and rural poverty was widespread on both
sides of the color line
these rosenwald facilities were
typically constructed
maintained and partially funded
by the populations that they served
becoming
centers of local social life and sources
of community pride
over the years to construct the
buildings rosenwald contributed 4.4
million dollars
or what today would be nearly 80 million
dollars
and importantly 4.7 million dollars
came from local black communities in the
form of cash
labor land and materials
washington and rosenwald had launched a
challenge grant
program that ultimately led to the
unprecedented construction
of more than five thousand school
buildings
four thousand nine hundred seventy seven
schools
two hundred seventeen teachers homes
and 163 shop buildings in
15 states from maryland to texas
all dedicated to the education of black
students
while the required donation from african
american communities
amounted to double taxation their
leaders nonetheless
called on residents to organize
fundraising drives
to cover their share of each new school
get busy laurel or hang your heads in
shame
admit admonished the prince george's
colored public school trustees in a 1924
report
describing the existing pitiful
buildings in the town of laurel
these efforts to build or renovate new
school buildings were impressive
in one instance struggling sharecroppers
set aside an area planted with cotton as
the quote
rosenwald patch end quote and donated
the profits from its sale
to the school children saved pennies and
snuff boxes
and at one fundraising rally an old man
who had been a slave offered his life
savings of 38 dollars to quote
see the children of my grandchildren
have a chance end quote
in the years between world war one and
world war ii
the rosenwald schools helped close the
gap between white and black
academic achievement researchers at the
chicago federal reserve
concluded that in the regions where the
rosenwald rural schools initiative
built most of its five thousand schools
the education gap between southern born
black and white males
narrowed sharply in areas such as school
attendance
literacy and cognitive test scores
using census data and world war ii
records
the researchers found that rosen's
rosenwald's program
explained a stunning 40 percent
narrowing of the racial education gap
while the rosenwald schools were
thriving a major case was being
litigated over segregation in 1954.
the supreme court made a landmark ruling
that school segregation was
unconstitutional
in brown versus board of education the
fundamental premise was that quote
separate is inherently
unequal end quote so exclusively black
or white schools were now outlawed
so a decision intended to improve
outcomes for black children
assumed separate had to mean inferior
the terrible irony is that decision
actually had the perverse impact of
making the very
existence of the rosenwald schools a
violation of the law
so even with its extraordinary record of
success
the rosenwald schools were quickly
abandoned
despite student protests over their
closing and demolition
most of the schools were gone by the
1970s
the rosenwald schools remain today one
of the greatest examples of strong
partnership across racial lines
black excellence and ironically the
victim
of unintended consequences fast forward
to today
while progress has been made with more
than three million
black students enrolled in college today
there are still
deep academic racial disparities in
pockets of american society
for example of the nearly 2 000 public
school students beginning high school in
the south bronx
where i led a network of charter schools
in 2015
only 2 percent of kids in this district
graduated ready for college four years
later
a shocking 98 percent of students
either dropped out of high school before
completing their senior year
or they did manage to graduate but would
still be required to take remedial
classes in community college
due to low math and reading scores on
state exams
by contrast charter public schools in
the south bronx
continue to outperform their district
peers in both
math and reading in third in third
through eighth grade by a substantial
margin
it comes as no surprise that parents in
these predominantly
black and hispanic communities
encompassing two of the poorest
congressional districts in the country
are
desperate for higher quality education
options
the new york city charter center reports
that in the bronx alone
more than 25 000 families
applied for just over 9 000 available
seats
in bronx charter schools this
overwhelming demand
demonstrates that parents want the best
for their children
and should be given the power of choice
many of these parents may have faced
racial discrimination and other
challenges
in their own lives and fear that their
children might as well
but they know that a great education
can make a huge difference they do not
believe that their children are doomed
to be shackled
by the horrors of america's legacy of
slavery
they know that if teachers had the
highest of expectations
and were empowered with a curriculum
that could help their children
develop character-based strengths like
integrity resiliency
and agency the belief that you can be
the master of your own destiny
then those children could lead life on
their own
terms even in the face of structural
barriers
that is why i must mention the 1619
project
a major initiative and series of essays
from the new york times magazine
for a year the authors have repeated the
claim that the country's
quote true founding end quote was 1619
and not 1776 when the declaration of
independence was signed
1619 claims that america was founded as
a slaveocracy
not a democracy that anti-black racism
runs in the very dna of the country
the 1619 project also claims that
america's founding ideals were false
when they were written
and that the nation was founded on a lie
despite the fact that the 1619 project
has been discredited by dozens of the
most well-respected historians
in the country particularly the claim
that the civil war was fought to defend
slavery
the new york times was not satisfied
with just the special edition
of the magazine they partnered with the
pulitzer center
to create a curriculum that has now been
adopted in thousands of classrooms
school districts in chicago illinois
washington dc and buffalo new york began
implementing the project
in their k-12 course materials
these are some of the lowest
academically performing
schools in the country
an educator who has spent the last 10
years working with families
who believe and want their child to have
the american dream
the last thing their children need to
hear is
false information about our country yes
america has a terrible history of
slavery and oppression
but america is not defined solely by its
legacy of slavery
we want all children to know of the
legacy of
excellence alongside the legacy of
slavery
and and the lessons that are relevant to
all american children
there are innumerable examples of
individuals
and groups that have gone from
persecution
to prosperity by embracing america's
founding ideals
of family free enterprise faith
hard work and entrepreneurship that is
why i'm
so proud to say that in the same spirit
that booker t
washington demonstrated to envision
how education could be a pathway to
prosperity
how he had an idea to build a network of
schools
throughout the south even in the face of
bitter
and often lethal racial discrimination
well today a group of talented black
scholars and activists
have come together to do the same this
initiative called
1776 unites is led by bob woodson
for 40 years bob woodson developed a
list of 10
principles that he has used in order to
help
local communities transform
struggling neighborhoods and to empower
the people within them
these 10 principles include competence
integrity transparency
resilience witness
innovation inspiration
agency access
and grace these ten
principles now undergird a new
1776 unites curriculum
which will ultimately develop into a
k-12 program
for all schools wherever character
formation is happening
for children every lesson will connect
back to one
or more of the woodson principles
the 1776 unites curriculum offers
authentic inspiring stories from
america's past
and present that show what is best
in our national character and what our
freedom
makes possible even in the most
difficult circumstances 1776 unites
includes two major components
a look back and a look forward
the look back maintains a special focus
on stories
and lesson plans that celebrate black
excellence
reject victimhood culture and showcase
african americans past and present who
have prospered
by embracing americans found america's
founding ideals
of free enterprise family hard work
entrepreneurship and
two examples include biddy mason an
amazing woman who was born a slave
but died a millionaire and a
philanthropist
and elijah mccoy a son of escaped slaves
who became a talented engineer and
inventor
whose products were so superior that
inferior knockoffs were created to the
point that when
engineers went to buy mccoy's products
and were offered the copies
they said no i want the real mccoy
many americans may know that phrase but
do not know it is connected to a black
engineer
the son of slaves these are just two
of the multitude of stories that we will
be that will be
in the look back section of the 1776
unites curriculum
the look forward component includes
units that teach
life lessons that help the next
generation
understand the series of life decisions
that give them the greatest likelihood
of economic success
as they make choices as they make their
passage
into young adulthood despite real racial
barriers that are out there
there are millions of examples of black
excellence
we constantly study poverty what can we
learn
from black americans who've been
successful in pursuing the american
dream
and their decisions around education
work
marriage and children for example
teaching the data
associated with what's called the
success sequence
the data that shows if you finish a high
school degree
secure a full-time job of any kind so
you learn the dignity and discipline of
work
and if you have children marriage first
98 of the people who followed those
steps
avoid poverty and the vast majority end
up in the middle class or beyond
that's the kind of information that
young people of all races need to know
to increase their likelihood of being
economically successful
in the case of my own parents that is
how they achieved the american dream
and made it possible for me to do the
same
i often wonder what would have happened
if my parents had not
acquiesced and instead insisted that i
attend the annex with almost all white
students
would i have exhibited the same level of
ownership over my learning
as i did when i convinced them to grant
me my wish to stay
yet in allowing me to forge a path that
went against their better judgment
my parents taught me a valuable lesson
my
effort could and would have to influence
my outcomes
at the time i felt an enormous added
responsibility
to make my parents decision worth the
trust
that they had placed in me i am
convinced
the feeling that i had on that long ago
sunday evening
the faith i was expressing in myself
and appealing to my parents to
reluctantly
accept was what i now understand
to be my sense of personal agency
that self-belief was the precursor to
the ensuing efforts and actions
necessary for me to fulfill the
commitment that i had made to my parents
and most importantly to myself
but what was also important was the fact
that my parents had the ability
to choose and to chart a path through
education to make life better for me
and by extension the next generation it
is through this type of innovation and
commitment
whether it be booker t washington or bob
woodson or my parents
that young americans of all races can
understand
that even while race has been an issue
in our country
it is actually the power of education
the power of america's founding ideals
and our founding documents signed in
1776
that have within them the tools for
self-renewal
and self-betterment in chapter 13
of de tocqueville's america he said
quote the greatness of america
lies not in being more enlightened than
any other nation but rather in her
ability
to repair her faults end quote
i have always found that statement
compelling
because it resonates with the notion
that america
is always in pursuit of becoming a more
perfect union
while the founders laid out inspiring
ideals
we are in a constant effort to fully
live up to them
that is the critical story about race
and education
because how we make steady progress
is through reminding and embracing
those founding ideals helping our next
generation to do that
and not rejecting them thank you
you